so that's the mind the mind is like a
GPS it's a computer it's someone wakes
up has a cup of coffee they break the
cup of coffee and they usually say I'm
going to have a bad day hundreds of
thousand people over the year it's like
I break a cup of coffee something
happens see I'm going have a bad day and
then the brain looks for evidence so in
New York we go to the train I get on the
train and the train is delayed but the
train is always delayed but because
because I say I'm going to have a bad
day the GPS see I'm having a bad day
then I get on the train EV right and in
New York they sub ways I don't know if
you ever took it there's three seats and
and there's me and someone else and
there's someone walking towards you and
you're like I know they're not going to
try to fit in between us there's no way
they're going to try to fit in between
us and then they come and they try to
fit in between you and now half of your
skin is on the seat and you say see I'm
having a bad day and then in New York we
have this people that we lovingly call
the Onion people because they have this
odor sometimes and when they sit next to
you you start tearing up and and and so
now I'm tearing up and I say see I'm
having a bad day then we get to the job
and and you get to the job and that
coworker who doesn't give you a minute
to like get your coffee they're all in
your face see I'm having a bad day
because the mind the brain looks for
evidence Neuroscience has shown that we
have these Pathways in our brain I know
you've done a lot of work featuring Joe
despenza and the pathways that fire
together wire together right so all that
is is the program you know I'm not
making a big enough impact as a program
and then the brain looks for evidence so
we want to go into the program and
rewire
it all right believe Nation we are back
another episode of tell me why I suck
and we have a return guest Mr Devin
banderson mindset coach for the Stars
how we doing man I'm doing great best
day of my life
EV so Deon was on before uh that was
actually a private conversation that we
just decided to make public because why
not now this is the official one that we
know we're going public with and Deon
gave me some homework of what I need to
do from the last time it was watch uh a
movie like that he called the black
Godfather well that is called the black
Godfather which I did uh what is 35
million subscribers feel like and then
what are some of the lowgrade thoughts
and uh he texted me this morning he he
Instagram dm' me this morning he like
brother bring your homework like dude
you don't know I was I was reading it
last night I was refreshing it this
morning I've got my book right here in
front of me like I'm set I'm ready to go
and uh round two so where do you want to
take this man what do next well first
off I want to acknowledge you man you
know I I think that and believe nation
and everybody who's tuning in I think
it's really important to see uh it's no
mistake and success leaves Clues it's no
mistake why you've reached the level of
success that you are because the way you
took on the homework was extraordinary
you're like my ideal client right
because you didn't just go through the
motions you took the essence of why you
were getting the homework right there
were three distinct um assignments and I
loved how not only you took it on but
you shared it with uh your community so
if you haven't seen that part of the
last video where EV shares his like how
he did the homework assignments I think
that in and of itself is a lesson for
people of if you want
transformation right you know there's a
difference between information and
transformation
a lot of people get a lot of information
in it's like let me just get a lot of
information but transformation is when
you really take it into Mind Body Spirit
and you look at everything like this
assignment as how does this apply to me
right like you could have took on the
black Godfather like I'm not black I'm
not a Godfather but you didn't take it
on like that right you took it on like
how does this apply to me and and I just
want to acknowledge you uh for that my
man it was really powerful cool I I mean
I love the I've never heard of Clarence
before he's he is the black Godfather I
took two pages of notes I don't know if
you want to kind of go through it or not
but uh I got two pages on the black
Godfather I got one page on what does 35
million subscribers feel like and I got
one page on low great thoughts and uh
the reason for this show is to take
people behind the scenes of hey I'm not
perfect tell me why I suck bring experts
on they they pour in the me and in my
learning hopefully the audience learn
something as well so uh appreciate you
coming back and giving me some extra
feedback and I'm excited for round two I
don't know where round two so this is
what we'll do cuz we really want to
point towards the low grade thoughts and
rewiring on neurop Pathways right that
that's third and I love that you said
that was the least favorite of the
assment right you went in you went into
the sauna so we'll talk about that whole
experience in a minute what I want to do
first is you know there was something in
our last conversation where I heard
something in you which is why I assigned
the black Godfather and I think that you
pointed to it in your homework right so
what were the things that I I think
would be helpful what were the things
that stood out the most about that um
watching that documentary and how it
applies to you so first off there was it
was a good documentary and that we
shared like they shared his point of
view and his interviews and he had a lot
of great quotes that I wrote down uh but
then also there's a lot of people
sharing their perspective on him and so
you get to see kind of the other side
whether it's Sean comes or David geffin
you know a bunch of people from the
industry sharing their thoughts one of
the things that um came up consistently
and David geffin said it at the end and
I got I got the exact quote here was
like uh where was it I don't know how he
makes a living he never used to charge
for anything yeah and that came up a
couple times uh and I that was the
number one feedback that I get when I'm
with my peers and the the people kind of
you know big names in my industry uh
it's like we don't know how makes money
we don't we don't know how like how we
could pay him uh and I saw that what's
that you sorry to interrupt like you
were in I remember Mastermind with
Brandon buad and and the whole crew and
and that's what they were pressing you
on right like hey you got to tell us how
to make money yeah yeah it was uh for
that group you know everybody had their
chance to go around and ask a question
and mine was tell me how I suck like I
don't have a question yeah you guys know
me tell me tell me my blind spot and it
was Bron and Dean graziosi and and Tom
Bilu and Lisa Bilu and Jamie K Lima
those are like the the five main people
who are kind of not beating up on me but
pouring into me and that was the number
one F I like dude I just want to cut you
a check like how do I pay you I don't
know what you do yeah you're always
giving and helping us with what we're
doing and like we've never paid you
anything I don't know how you make money
uh and and their specific advice was
like we you got to get clear on that cuz
we'd love to pay you uh and that was you
know a takeaway but then in watching the
black Godfather like well well he
Clarence kind of figured it
out so was I like that was that was a
nice little aha moment there uh I you
know so that kind of on the right path
um possibly I'm still open you know like
with all of this stuff it's anything
that I find that I am uh against is
either nothing you know like if somebody
gives me feedback it's either and I
don't I don't receive it well it's
either nothing or it's the whole thing
it's like either I'm so blocked that man
you're hitting on something huge if I'm
that against it yeah um
I love how he was saying I don't have
problems I have
friends and uh I don't what is it I
don't make speeches I make deals so he
was a he was a a big dealmaker I don't
know that I consider myself a great
dealmaker although I I am very
fascinated by business models and so
that might translate into I see things
differently in terms of how people can
create deals but I haven't been like the
guy making the deals so that's
interesting he had a lot of parties and
always having people over and networking
and I'm I'm definitely don't see myself
as that guy like we don't really have a
ton of people
over introverts so but it's fine it's
like it's taking the pieces that you can
learn from uh it's it's like okay how do
how how can I apply some of these things
uh to my life one of the things I loved
like he was always kind of on on trend
on culture fighting for equality making
sure people didn't get screwed on their
deals um you know I'm not the expert on
black history uh in America but he was
the guy helping people get great deals
he got Hank Aaron like the biggest ever
deal like Coca-Cola has a brand
sponsorship uh he was making sure like
Sean comes that he was making sure that
everybody in the community wasn't
getting screwed over on their deals you
know one of the things I see in you EV
is that you in your own way are that guy
you're like the ultimate connector right
so whenever people have come up in my
world even with uh if they want to scale
their YouTube right right like the way
you make yourself available right to
connect with people to like really be
behind the scenes you I want you to see
that you are actually a driving force
for for Change and good in the world in
in the area in which you serve people in
your highest form and I think that it's
been people who spanned all kinds of
cultures that sent you away who you've
been and and every time they come back
and they're so grateful because you
you've taken them from here and then
opened up a new opportunity for them to
see a bigger way to serve so I can you
see that I want to make sure you see
that yeah I mean and helping people for
sure uh I what I what the missing piece
for me is I don't see myself as the guy
who's like connecting other people
together I'm not saying like you need to
be with this person um but maybe I do I
mean I remember uh there's a channel
called kism on command I don't know if
you ever heard of them or not but it's
all about Charisma they've got bigger
than me like millions of subscribers and
uh we were at an event in California for
YouTubers and after that event he made a
video on his Channel about how I'm Evan
Caro was like the best networker that he
seen or something like that he like me
what are you talking about I have I
don't like connect with that at all I'm
shy and introverted and like not talking
to people but then when he broke it down
he was saying things like uh he made
these introductions to me and all I did
was listen it's was like hey Charlie
you're you're looking for this oh you
know you should talk to Sean about that
should talk to this guy and so I just
wanted him to not it was his first time
there I wanted him to not feel kind of
alone and like not knowing who to talk
to so was just trying to make a couple
of introductions from The Limited people
that I knew it wasn't like that I knew
everybody yeah but then he made this you
know he's the expert on Charisma and
then making this video about how I'm
this master networker so there might be
something there you want to see if
there's something because I noticed that
there was some resistance it was like
you can connect with everyone and you
went right to I don't know if I I
connect with everyone that's
aspirational I'm a pretty shy guy right
so so we just want to it's just just
breadcrumbs right we just want to look
at at like what's possible there the
other thing that stood out I know you
learn from everybody and I think the
fact that you study business plans you
know you you can connect dots quicker
than most the other thing is it was a
very quick rejection of the celebrity
celebrity right it's like I want to I I
want to hit 35 million I'm the celebrity
celebrity but you know I remember seeing
uh someone that's very well known who
said you are like they were singing your
you are the guy he was saying you are
the guy on YouTube I and um this is
someone everybody follows and um so we
want to look at that right where there's
some resistance just it's just
breadcrumbs because for you to to create
big to 35 million where you're going to
create you have to step into it what got
you here is not going to get you there
you got to step into a new way of being
and um I want to give you a distinction
here okay on are you down okay I'm yeah
I'm so down so this
distinction is called the junction of
creation okay and and the junction of
creation is like if if you come to a
crossroads right there's two people who
come together and there's an opportunity
to create big
now what happens is you you're such a
giver EV and sometimes the best givers
uh well not Sometimes the best givers
actually have to also include being some
of the greatest
receivers right so so I noticed that for
instance like celebrity celebrity was a
rejection you don't call on your friends
for help like you said maybe I should
call on your friends that was part of
your homework right um so the junction
of creation is I want you to picture
someone coming to you with a
gift and the gift is like I'm giving you
a cake and and you like cake let's say
carrot cake whatever what cake you like
do you like any cake let's go with
butter tarts butter tarts Canadian
delicacy yeah let's go with buttertart
so so someone comes with you with with
buttertart to give it to you and there's
an actual opportunity to receive it in a
way where you can receive it but they
feel appreciated as well
but what most people do is it's like uh
they they don't receive it they push it
back to the person that it almost like
it's like taking the cake and slamming
in the face and this is how it looks
when someone gives you an
acknowledgment there's something built
into uh you know false humility is the
highest form of
arrogance false humility is the highest
form of arrogance if if false humility
will get you a a seat in your life in
the stands of your life it will get you
a front row seat you won't be a player
on the court because it's like if people
if I accepted how brilliant I am or how
powerful I am or how much I make a
difference people wouldn't be able to
handle it so people shrink so and and
become falsely humble but it's actually
a form of arrogance so how that plays
out Evan is people will come to give you
an acknowledgement just anyone and
instead of accepting the acknowledgement
in the junction of creation people do
this thing like I don't know that's just
not me or they'll shrink or they'll say
no no no I'm not the you the man no
you're the man no you the man or or
someone will give you an acknowledgement
you'll be like well you know I couldn't
have did it without you they they
minimize the acceptance of the
acknowledgement can you hear that yeah
okay so like the celebrity celebrity N I
don't know if I'm I'm I'm kind of like
that you know it's you know there's like
a a resistance a push so I'm going to
give you I'm going to turn you into
either um you got two options here
you're going to either uh operate on a
master's degree level uh which is pretty
good or a doctorate level okay so so
here's how the junction of creation
happens because what happens is in the
junction of creation if someone gives me
an acknowledgement and I push it away or
I don't accept it appropriately then
there's no creation that happens it just
shuts it down the person
doesn't want to do as much for the other
person they might not even acknowledge
them again because it just wasn't wasn't
appreciated so I want you to uh just I'm
going to give you an example so I want
you to give me uh an acknowledgement I
just just any acknowledgement just any
type of mnow like for you
yeah Devin bandison is the celebrity
mindset
coach so here's the Master's Degree
response just quick ready MH thank
you that's it okay now give me another
acknowledgement I'm going to give you
the doctorate
response you gave me some homework that
I deeply appreciate and I love that you
followed up with me because it shows
that you're a master of your
craft thank you for
noticing thank you for
noticing so when you acknowledge me EV
and and you hear from me thank you for
noticing how do you hear that how do you
receive that great it h it it it still
comes off as as humble and not like you
being full of yourself and you're you're
also praising me back because you're
saying that I noticed right so that is
what I call the junction of creation so
if someone's coming your way and they're
saying hey man you're the celebrity
celebrity so I'm going to tell we gonna
play it now he hey f
you are the celebrities
celebrity thank you for noticing de my
man so now we got Dr Evan carmichel on
the on the set so let's just give it up
for Evan Dr Evan so what I want you to
start practicing as a distinction is
when people are coming to acknowledge
you you want to have that Junction of
creation expand you want to receive tell
them thank you for noticing because then
it keeps you in the game to to to create
big from there when you shut it down
either internally or externally the
creation stops so anyone you go around
from now on people are are sharing stuff
with you I want you to be Dr Evan thank
you for
noticing it's uh good homework all right
good we're gonna do it all right so
let's let's go on to the second
assignment what what let's go on to yeah
the second assignment you had second
assignment was what do 35 million
subscribers feel like
and for this one uh I mean for the black
Godfather I was pausing the movie I mean
I think I upset Nina I was pausing the
movie so many times to like write
something down it's made it made it
harder to follow the sto Ling because I
was pausing it so much uh but anyway so
then for the 35 million so the the
context is you know I had three and a
half million subscribers the goal is get
to 35 how do we 10x that and and Devin
said what does it feel like so you know
B do have right what what does it feel
like who do you have to be to be that
guy and so this one I I sat outside I
took some time you know just nice summer
day and just kind of let it flow through
me yeah um so would you want me to read
some of the things I put down or yep
okay what is 35 million subscribers feel
like I put uh being an important part of
people's daily routine being able to put
people on and give exposure being able
to open bigger doors and have a bigger
impact traveling more spreading the
message around the world Ripple effects
into culture fashion politics
Entertainment Sports making imagine
practical which was the lenon song yeah
making it practical creating a real
Community for people the family they
need and never had bringing more people
together instead of pushing them apart
making it okay for people to suck at the
start launching products people probably
wear and use symbols of identity
partnering with Titans outside of
thought leadership being a bigger
unifier creating easier programs for
people to follow spending less time on
smaller projects and tasks giving
responsibility away to people sooner
better Capt and Magic that happens
one-on-one better personal brand
storytelling and then what I'm currently
doing just bigger faster and better yeah
so when you did that what was the things
that stood out the most for
you the combination
of spreading more hope and belief and
optimism uh it feels like it's harder to
win these days by being positive
yeah and so it's like being that Force
for good when everything else is
negative uh and being able to bring
other people up like it's not that
people are negative it's just the ones
who are optimistic and positive aren't
loud enough that's all and so like being
that voice bringing people on just being
able to spread more hope and possibility
uh and then the second part was just in
the in the how of doing it of like doing
too many small things and moving to
bigger ideas and projects and handing
things off I I like tinkering I like
playing I like being in the thing and
but sometimes I Stay Well often I
probably stay in it too long before
handing it off to somebody
else and this whole thought about being
a Force for good in the world and like
the ne this isn't a new story from you
right like that the negative is
overriding the positive it it takes
longer it's harder for the guy who stays
above it and really is a positive force
that that's been going on since at least
I I've known you I know that's been a
pretty strong
thought Pro thought yeah I mean that's
always the thing that'll get me going
the most is like hey let's go change it
the world man like when when we sat and
talked about your content it's like dude
we need more Devon in the world you got
man on the street whatever it is like
the world needs you and your message uh
it's why I do this show it's why I do
all the content that I put up it's why I
help the people that I help it's like we
I want to spread more that's that's
always the thing that's going to get me
is let's go change the world and have a
big impact yeah and and I see I mean you
just like your whole physical energy
lights up when we talk in that realm and
then on the other end what I've noticed
is like when you talk about the people
whose voices are the loudest now right
it's almost like this pull I'm just
paraphrasing just from me kind of
knowing you it's like you still think
that there's some kind of pull that like
the negative voices
are kind of outshine Shing or maybe um
louder and and being heard more right
and and maybe it would be I don't know
here's a thought is it like maybe 35
million would go faster if I went to the
other side and like was more negative
around things like some of my colleagues
have been oh I mean I for sure I would
go faster but it's like doing it the
right way right like the first the first
tribute video top 10 that I did was on
Kanye yeah because I said you can learn
from him yeah as a of like my friend
posting something and I made it just for
him to like go watch this because you
should learn from Kanye even if he does
some stupid things and may say the wrong
things like cool you can still learn
from him right uh but if I did top 10
stupidest thing Kanye have said dude
that would blow up way faster yeah but
uh it's not just about hitting the 35
million is doing it in the right way
because otherwise I would burn out like
how have I stay consistent over what 14
years of making YouTube videos yeah
because I still love the thing you know
I love the process so uh um yeah it's
not 35 million at at uh at any cost uh
it's doing it the right way so yeah I I
love that you know one of my favorite
questions I ask clients is like what
what are you willing to put at
risk for your
aliveness right so so for me when you
talk about Imagine John Lenin like like
doing it the right way being this Force
for good I see Evan in his alive
right so the question is one there's two
it's like what what am I willing to put
at risk and what am I not willing to put
at risk for my
aliveness right so I think that there's
something here of like hey I'm not
willing to be out of Integrity uh
meaning like go negative and go dark on
people uh I'm not willing to put that at
risk but what are you willing to put at
risk for your
aliveness I don't know I don't know what
I I guess how I'm trying to make that
make sense as what am I not putting at
risk that I might I maybe should yeah um
I know there are you know I look at um
this is exhibit at Walt Disney World I
don't know the last time you went to
Disney but oh yeah I love Disney there's
this really ex there's a small exhibit
that nobody goes to which is Walt
Disney's story it's like the man behind
the dream or The Man Behind the mouse or
something like that and uh I just like
going through there and spending you
know an hour in there just looking at
the story and the kids will go to the
Indiana Jones spectacular thing and
watch that and I'll I'll spend that time
because they don't want it it's too
boring for them uh and what always
shocked me about it was he put
everything on the line every time like
even when he didn't had a success he put
it all on the line again to launch the
next thing like all on the line to
launch Snow White all on the line to W
to launch Disney World uh Disneyland Etc
and it's like I don't I at least maybe
financially I don't I I I can't see
myself doing that and uh maybe that's
right maybe that's wrong um but it's
it's always
uh uh inspiring you know it's like he
believed in it so much that he would put
everything on the line to go and chase
this dream down yeah so I don't know
that's where that's where my mind went
as you I love that and it's like it
doesn't have to be Financial it's like
for
me you know one of the things and I see
this in you it's like when I always they
always told me if if I'm in the if I'm
the smartest in the room you're in the
wrong rooms right so I'm always looking
to get into rooms where you know I'm
learning I'm growing you see me most
alive when I'm learning I'm growing in
rooms we've been in rooms together and
that's my aliveness so what I'm willing
to put at risk for instance when I go to
those rooms is I'm willing to ask a
question somebody may think is a dumb
question I I'm I'm I'm willing to not
look good all the time right I'm willing
to break an awkward silence right um in
my with my wife we have the most loving
relationship in the world and in my it's
aliveness like this is the relationship
where we are totally ourselves and we're
alive and what I'm willing to put at
risk in my relationship with my wife
is temporary happiness for me sharing
honestly with Integrity the truth so so
we have a relationship where you know I
I remember one day um I wake up and and
people ask me you know how you doing and
I always say I think about it I say
that's a great question and I say today
is actually the best day of my life and
I mean it it's not just happy talk it
means like you know I if I can't find
today being the best day cuz this is the
only clock I have in my house now right
now followed by now if I can't find the
best day today then I'll be looking it
looking for it my whole life and and
most people say well well what' you do
what happened did you win the lot no no
no that's that's the point I don't wait
for things or circumstances to determine
my day I just choose it right so one day
um my wife was going through something
in the morning she wasn't you know
feeling and at her best and she says you
know how doing today and I say today is
actually the best day of my life and she
looks at me and she says can you please
just not say that today right and I
looked at her and I said I love you and
you can count on me that I will be
saying that today right now in the
moment it was it was temporary she
wasn't happy but for my aliveness right
I am not willing to like shrink in that
moment and and what happens is she comes
back back to me later and says I
appreciate you cuz you're a stand you
know you're not
wishy-washy so so there's certain things
whether it's in relationships or in
business it's like what am I willing to
risk put at risk so for me in that
situation I'm willing to put temporary
happiness with with for my aliveness in
the relationship if that makes
sense so that's somewhere where you may
want to look at hey what am I willing to
put at risk for my aliveness of this
this John Lenin imagine belief you know
world that you're creating for people I
don't know what I am willing to put at
risk that I'm not currently and I guess
that's the unlock right it's like okay
so you know people would say I'm even a
series like this where it's like hey I'm
not the expert I'm the subject come and
come and pour into me and like let's
make it public you know I don't know
where it's going to go great uh but it
doesn't feel that risky either yeah you
know like I like pulling back the
curtain and showing that I'm not perfect
and what I'm working on and trying to
get better at like it doesn't feel like
a big risk so I don't know I don't know
I don't know how to increase the risk or
what maybe would even be easy to to give
up that I'm not currently doing
um I don't know so I love the answer I
don't know because I have two responses
to that for you you ready yeah who
should I
ask if you don't know who should I ask
okay I'm going to ask Deon manison no no
right or and here's the second one if
you did know if you did
know what would it
be if I did know what would it be well
who should I ask Deon bison so then that
just solves the problem and I don't have
to ask a second well that's why we're
here ladies gent you know better than
that right because the greatest see if
someone says I come to me I'll solve the
problem run away way my power is in my
listening and I point back where the
answer really is which is right there
within you 100% yeah like to that first
one I I it's uh people can just give
perspective But ultimately it's up to me
to have to decide like who is who is it
to who's going to tell me what I should
be giving up or risking uh you know I
don't I don't know I don't have an
answer but it's like it's something it's
worth thinking about if I'm looking at
homework after that it's like
what what do I what else do I need to
risk that I'm not risking
um but let's not just kind of cop out
and and uh give me till the next time to
think about it uh well done well cat
well caught what what comes to mind
immediately you know I think uh the
first in coming is the
being being liked may not be the right
word but I don't I don't like uh
controversy or uh confusion or uh
negativity and sometimes when you
go sometimes when I look at some of my
peers I guess who are bigger there's a
lot of there's a lot of uh they embrace
the negativity and controversy so like
how do I build it in a way where I'm not
they're doing it they're just doing
their thing and and sharing when you say
that you mean when they're sharing
they're focused more on
negative not necessarily they're focused
on uh they're picking a side uhuh and
they think it's the right side and
that's fine but there's very few things
that I'll pick a side on yeah like I
I'll the stuff that I'll talk about is a
lot more you know generic like belief
and optimism hope and like I don't I
don't know how to solve the Middle East
crisis dude I don't know I don't know I
don't know how to solve the who's going
to be the next president and what you
know I'll see both sides
right uh and I'm I don't know if that I
mean the the positive is that you can
like you can get along with anybody and
and I'm seeking to learn and try to
understand and the negative is you don't
uh you don't get as
much strength in any of the individual
communities
um so I mean I don't even know where I'm
going with this I mean I think I think
uh one of the challenges that I've had
with my agent over the years is he
always wants me to take a stand on
things like okay so what whatever is
going on in the Middle East right now
what do you think he's like I don't know
I see both sides he like you're the
worst man you're like the most
Canadian but and that's a positive but
then you know so I don't a lot of the
people that I look up to they don't
necessarily lean into the negative but
they're taking aside which then by
default becomes negative to some people
right so if anybody like if you said man
I talked to Evan and it was kind of a
waste of time or I talked to Evan and he
told me to do something and I was really
stupid or you know and sometimes things
get misconstrued or sometimes I was
wrong or sometimes you it was a f-
minute conversation we couldn't go in
deep and like it was there wasn't enough
context to make the right decision like
if that but if I felt that out of a call
or a meeting or interaction that you
were upset at me or I gave I steered you
in the wrong direction or I was a
whatever dude that would like I would I
would have to make it up to to you you
know i' have to make it up to you um we
have a program called movement makers
where we're training thought leaders and
you know every now and then somebody
leaves a program for whatever
reason uh and I'll I'll make a personal
video to everybody you know I I welcome
everybody and I'll I'll send a personal
message to anybody who leaves yeah uh
because I don't want anybody having a
bad taste in our mouth and that might be
a limitation of uh you know getting
you're going to get the 35 million
you're going to get people who have a
bad taste in your mouth um and we
already do have it you like they're
already as much as we're trying to be
positive and spread hope that you'll
still get the the random comments that
that show up
um yeah so I don't want people having a
bad T if I'm trying to spread hope and
optimism and belief I don't want people
having a bad taste in their mouth when
they're interacting with anything that
I'm putting up yeah and where does that
come for how long can you track that
back of like I don't want people have a
bad taste in my mouth can it does it go
all the way back where does that come
from I don't want people having a bad
taste in their mouth I mean probably
childhood somewhere yeah can you think
of like the first time so so there's
before I say I don't want to have a bad
taste in my mouth there's something that
occurs before that right so what happens
is like in childhood for
instance I I remember six years old
being packed in the back of my Mazda's
my mom had a Mazda 626 and and they had
all the clothes and we were leaving and
my father and my my grandma was on the
steps and I remember saying there was
this thing a command like you're not
you're not
lovable cuz you didn't keep your parents
together right so what happened was you
know there's this fight or flight that
happens within us it's like I never want
to feel like that again so we create a
personality and identity so I be became
kind of like the chameleon the life of
the party I the chameleon was like I can
I can kind of get in any room and adapt
to everyone because I didn't want to
feel like I'm not lovable and what
happened was this became my winning
formula right it worked the chameleon
the life of the part it worked all these
years it got me a high level of success
until it didn't work anymore until it
was like every the guy from Queens
Everybody Loves Raymond everybody loves
Deon but Devon right because I I became
this chameleon and what happens is we do
it everyone has it it's called a racket
one of my teachers used to call it a
racket cuz because it's like we're all
racketeers you ever heard of a
racketeer you know like a what's a
racket to you like when someone's
running a
racket oh I was thinking like numbers
back in the day yeah yeah numbers right
so so you remember the word fronting
Don't Front yeah what does that mean
don't be fake don't be don't be somebody
that you're not right so where that
comes from is U Back in the Days the
racketeers had
storefronts right so the storefront was
like a candy shop and and youd go in the
candy shop not cuz something's wrong
with you because everyone loves candy
and you went in the candy shop because
there was a payoff are you with me yep
okay so this is where we want to look
for you it's like I If because you said
something big Dev if you think I did
something wrwy or something I have to
make that up I would feel terrible so
what we're talking about is mine was I'm
not lovable and then I created I'm a
chameleon so if you go back to your
thought and we'll talk about a racket in
a minute it's like what was the thing
that triggered this hey I got to make
sure people like me what what was the
thing it's a persistent complaint you
have or or command you say about
yourself that goes all the way back I'm
thinking the first distinction I would
probably make is I
don't I think it's more I don't need
people to I don't care if they like me I
just want them to not not like me yeah
not like so can you can you track that
back as far as you can it's like where
was the first time where you like I
don't want them to not like me yeah bad
I left someone with a bad taste in their
mouth and it bothered me if I don't know
who should I ask that's
right or if I did now what would it be
we're going under the layers now this is
why yeah yeah I get it stuff I haven't
thought about the first time
that I left someone with a bad taste in
their
mouth I mean I'm thinking of I'm just
trying to go back in childhood as as far
back as possible I'm thinking about you
know in um remember in my art class uh I
had a assignment that my teacher didn't
give me a good Mark on and there like
draw a uh or paint a window with a
sunset or something and I I
did I I did that but she wanted more and
then my mom went in and like fought with
her and said well listen you you asked
him to do this and he did this why you
giving him a bad Mark um I don't know if
I was really was I leaving a bad taste
in my Teacher's mouth that I really care
good maybe forget maybe so so if I leave
a bad taste in my mouth in in in other
people's mouth if I leave a bad taste or
they have a bad experience of me what
does that what did you what does that at
that age what do you make that mean
about you like if I do that then I'm
what well that I that I failed right I
mean I'm a failure that I mean I didn't
do well on
the I didn't do well on that on that uh
assignment yep so let's just look at
failure I'm a failure
can you can you look at any other points
in your life where that came up it's
like because I can see in some of your
other work it's like this not happening
fast enough not impact not big an impact
people don't help me the plan isn't
working right got to that yet we haven't
even got to you I know I know but I'm G
to connect this for you so can you see
where like if something goes wrong is
your first like you may have hidden it
but can you see where I'm a failure
could come up sure yeah if if I've
disappointed somebody then I'm a failure
sure yeah so let's just say that that's
your
racket okay I'm a failure so if we're
building a house underneath the scene
and this is before we even get to the
next work say you're Racket and here we
run a racket all of us are racketeers we
all run a racket I'm not good enough I'm
a failure people don't support me um I
I'm a fraud uh I'm not talented enough
I'm not smart enough those are all
rackets they're not truths they're just
thoughts that we believed over time and
they became truths okay now the reason
why we run a racket is because there's a
payoff we love going into the candy shop
here's some examples of payoffs you
ready it allows me to be right and make
others
wrong it allows me to
dominate or avoid
domination it allows me to win or not
lose it allows me to avoid
responsibility okay so the I'm a failure
you run it not cuz something's wrong
with you you run it because there's a
payoff sure yeah 100% so out of those
pay what what are the ones that stuck
out the most for
you uh the payoff would
be that it leads to success like if the
people that I'm work with are happy with
me then it leads to the things that I
want right now I want you to see the
other side you're running a racket
called I'm a
failure I'm a failure is behind
everything and the payoff to I'm a
failure is it allows you to be right
about it be you being a failure make
other people wrong avoid responsibility
dominate not be dominated win or lose Al
those are very specific ones okay um
domination is not I probably just go win
or lose win or lose right so so right up
until this point the reason why you run
I'm a failure or I can't leave a bad
taste is not cuz something's wrong with
Evan is because we love candy we love
going in the candy shop so but now
you're in the candy shop and you hear
the door lock and you're like uhoh they
ain't no and they say come down to the
basement and now you realize uh-oh Not
only was there a payoff in the basement
they got all the bad stuff the drugs the
guns is like you know and and they say
now you realize very quickly that
there's been a
cost and here's some versions of what it
costs
us
satisfaction
fulfillment
Vitality
self-expression
Joy so this running a racket like I
don't want to leave a bad taste I'm a
failure if I do right there's something
there's a cost it's costing you
something this if I if I did something
Devon wrong I got to make it right I got
to make it right like this running this
thing this this Tech this system this
technology in your head is costing you
and it could cost us Vitality
satisfaction fulfillment
self-expression what what what comes to
mind of what it's costing you bigness
yeah yeah you know like if the goal is
to get to 35 million subscribers then
the bigger you get the more you're going
to disappoint people there you go so up
until now what you want to see ev is
you've been running a subconscious
program right where being
liked and
winning seemed more important than your
bigness I don't want to leave a bad
taste has seemed more important than
your bigness okay and it's costing you
your 35 million in many ways it's
costing you the liveness we talked about
cuz cu the more people you you serve I
see you when you're in rooms and you
serve you become more alive so you want
to know that like we don't run this CU
something's wrong with us we run it
because this is up until now the payoff
have seemed more important than what
it's cost you you ever you ever hear the
old saying in in relationships they say
do you want to be happy or do you want
to be
right and some people their racket is
it's way more important to be right than
to be
happy so what what I just want you to
see now before we even get to this next
work which is going to all bring it
together is that you have a racket
called I'm a failure and and how you run
the fail the racket of I'm a failure is
I don't don't want to leave a bad taste
in everybody's mouth and up until now
the payoff of winning you know and and
and being right about that has seemed
more important than the
bigness so we have to make sure that
like we understand that it's no that
payoff is not even worth what it's
costing me anymore M it's the thing
keeping me from this next level can you
see that yeah 100% all right anything
you want want to share about that
anything you noticing in this
conversation uh the question I just
wrote down was okay so if if that's a
scenario then what would I do if I
wasn't afraid of disappointing people
yeah
yeah yeah there goes a smile I don't
know and look and it's not look one
thing I heard you in my listening it's
like it's not an either or scenario it's
not like EV takes the high road he
doesn't get involved in any of this or
he takes a
right one of you your Brilliance is that
you can see both sides so maybe your
power is in understanding like boom
there's a difference between seeing both
sides and not just talking about
anything right so it had EV I'm just
going to stay here or I can see both
sides and I'm willing to share about it
I have my Game Changer live experiences
it's the most transformational weekend
on the planet and the and the people
come and one of the things I'm most
proud of in this space is the diversity
that I bring in the room I mean you can
have billionaires single moms you got
black white uh spent everything in the
room and what people start
realizing very quickly is we're more
alike than
different and and we what what has been
lost is that we have not learned how to
disagree without being
disagreeable like there's this listening
now in this world called if I'm right
you're wrong and I think that you have a
real power when you're not worried about
being a failure or having a bad taste in
people's mouth your voice is really that
voice of seeing both sides is is
something that I would encourage you to
embrace because that's where your power
your lane is it's not this lane or
someone else's Lane it's like that
that's your superpower that you can
actually see both sides that you can
bring a a a list listening a neutrality
to things to see hey I can see
where their point of view and their
point of view what's the most valuable
thing you're hearing right now in this
conversation oh there's a lot so thank
you I'm I'm now like instantly jump into
okay well so what am I gonna do right
like
it's got to take some action here guys
who who do I have to be so I can do
these things y um the two things popping
to mind I'm just trying to remember what
the Tupac quote was of the uh not I'm
not trying to be the president but I'll
light the mind of the next president or
something like that you remember what
that you know that quot I forg get the
exact quote yeah I know yeah but that
whole idea of like okay well I don't I
don't have to have in in in having a
voice I don't have to have the answer
even but I'm trying to spark a way of
thinking that somebody can come up with
an answer Bingo because a lot of these
things I don't I don't I don't even know
enough to have a final answer you asked
me something about YouTube or
entrepreneurship or whatever you got I
got a lot of answers but other things I
Mayan not know enough um but just the
way of thinking could Inspire the person
with the answer so that that connects um
and then I also took note of uh I did a
a post on um Instagram a while ago about
Elon Musk and Larry King uh who were
going back not Larry King uh Stephen
King uh they were going back in Forth
about the blue check and like it being
$8 or whatever to to pay for Twitter
verification like they they had this
whole back and forth and my post was
like guys you got like Elon Musk and
Stephen King with all of these you know
followers and influence and like just
genius brains like what if they use
their genius brains to fight for good
instead of them squabbling over you know
eight verification or not and so it's
not just seen both sides it's uh it's
changing the conversation and seeing a
bigger picture Lex fredman does that
really well where I I uh this's One Clip
he had where he had um Mark Zuckerberg
on and at the time Zuck and and Elon
were going back and forth and are they
going to fight or not in the cage match
or whatever and Elon had just said some
really disparaging things from
Zuckerberg and so Zuck comes on and most
people would ask Zuck like hey Elon said
these things like here's your chance man
big platform trying to punch back you
know let's go and that's how you get the
clicks and the views on the video but
his question was uh you know Elon said
these things about you and it's
unfortunate that he's being so negative
um what do you think he's done well in
his first 100 days of owning
Twitter you know this is like forcing a
positive narrative yeah and when they
were thinking about the fight everybody
was thinking well elon's bigger and he's
stronger and he's got a longer reach but
zck is younger and has done some Jitsu
or whatever uh you know who's going to
win and and Lex came out and said well
I'm just I'm happy that they're both
picking up martial arts because like
that does a lot for your your mind and
it does a lot for your inner peace and
just just taking a whole like I don't
even see that angle right taking a whole
different way and so there's a there's I
think there's uh even the fact that it
inspires me means that there's seeds to
turn that into something and that's
where it could risk disappointing people
on that you're taking like somebody's
going to be pissed lots of people will
be pissed because they're firmly on one
side and they don't they don't want to
hear that there's another perspective or
point of view that you can even think
about listening to the other side it's a
real big Insight you want willing to put
at risk and and one of the ways of being
that I've created myself to be is called
what people think of me is none of my
business I and and it's funny it's
because I can love people and I can love
you know and people's opinion of you is
going to shift no matter what and it's
like who am I going to be to create the
world that that I see that I want to
help contribute to so I acknowledge you
thank you for noticing yeah there you go
doctor thank you Dr Evan um all right so
here we go let's shift to the now that
is going to really that Foundation of
knowing your racket I'm I'm a failure
and up until
now you know the payoff has seemed more
important than the cost but now you're
seeing that the cost of your bigness is
not not
worth the payoff it's not worth being a
failure it's not worth I don't want to
leave a bad taste it's like I need to
understand that what it's costing me is
is way too much and it's not worth the
payoff can you see that yep good so that
leads us to these these low grade
thoughts yes okay so low grade thoughts
this was rough yeah uh and I mentioned
in my video because when I anytime I go
negative it's like instant i' i' like
twitch myself back to positive which can
I stop you there yeah yeah so by the way
that is not by accident right like you
have practiced over and I think you said
in the video it was like I um this
wasn't always the case so so the fact
that you have like had this response of
I go negative and then I can go into a
new pathway a neurop pathway is just a i
acknowledge you for the work you've done
to get here so that's just thank you for
noticing there you go so for this one
it's like as soon as I came up with
anything slightly negative we're like
snap back to positive like no like that
that serves me and it's a it's a pattern
that helps and for this exercise I got
to do my homework because dev's gonna
come on and slam me if I don't get this
I promise I would do it so I got to do
it so I went into the sauna yeah turned
crank the heat all the way up I ripped
the page out of my book and I started
like this page is like has dropped like
it's all it's all dried now but but uh
I'm sweating as I'm writing furiously to
try to get stuff out uh so that was a
that was a very painful uh I haven't I
haven't been that dark I don't know
maybe ever but um the you want me to
read what I yeah yeah okay so lowgrade
thoughts from my crazy SAA session uh
I'm not growing fast enough I'm not
making enough of an impact the plan
isn't working I don't know what to do
people won't help me I won't figure this
out I can't get people to care people
come for the slbs not my contribution I
haven't mobilized my subscribers my
content is not important enough I can't
pull this off I'm not bold enough to do
this I'm not taking the actions fast
enough the dark is more powerful than
the light I'm not bringing enough value
and I'm
stuck powerful really really great great
work and and what I want you to see as
we look at that
is that that list got I'm a failure
written all over it yeah I never said
the words but yeah can can you see that
so that's the interesting thing of the
racket it's like the subconscious
program that we don't even identify
until we see it and how you know it's
there is because you could probably
track it back like you did to Childhood
it's not something that just occurred a
year ago five years ago it's like I can
track this back okay so what I want you
to do is we're going to do a process
here and this will be um the most loving
thing you can do for yourself is these
these are the subconscious thoughts that
are that are occurring for you so if
we're building a
house how the world in which we step
into is based on our
listening and our language and we get
our listening from our like our thinking
so for instance if someone wakes up it's
like a GPS if I put 600 Green Street in
my GPS where do I end
up hopefully 600 Green Street
if I put, 1400 Waters Place where do I
end up, 1400 if I put 600 Green Street
in my GPS I don't end up at400 Waters
Place M so if I put I'm not making a big
enough impact where do I end
up right there right so that's the mind
the mind is like a GPS it's a computer
right so it's it's it's someone wakes up
has a cup of coffee they break the
coffee did I tell you this story it's
like they break the cup of coffee and
they usually say most people not is like
I'm going to have a bad day right they
stub their toe they're on the roong
right they they break the coffee they
break something in the morning most
people say that right wow really yeah I
know you know right like that's with a
lot of people I've been in room
thousands hundreds of thousands people
over the year it's like I break a cup of
coffee something happen see him I have a
bad day and then the brain looks for
evidence right 100% so in New York we go
to the train I get on the train and the
train is delayed but the train is always
delayed but because because I say I'm
going to have a bad day the GPS see I'm
having a bad day then I get on the train
EV right and in New York there Subways I
don't know if you ever took it there's
three seats and and there's me and
someone else and there's someone walking
towards you and you're like I know
they're not going to try to fit in
between us there's no way they're going
to try to fit in between us and then
they come and they try to fit in between
you and now half of your skin is on the
seat and you say see see I'm having a
bad day right and then in New York we
have this people that we lovingly call
the Onion people because they have this
odor sometimes and when when they sit
next to you you start like tearing up
and and and so now I'm tearing up and I
say see I'm having a bad day then we get
to the job and and you get to the job
and that coworker who doesn't give you a
minute like to to like get your coffee
they're all in your face you see I'm
having a bad day because the mind the
brain looks for evidence mhm so these
low grade thoughts is like these these
are the seeds of where now you have had
a practice where you you you catch and
replac them but we want to like really
go in there and get rid of them there's
so neuroplasticity neuro have has shown
the science of Neuroscience has shown
that we have these Pathways in our brain
right I know you've you've uh did a lot
of work featuring Joe dispenser and and
um the pathways that fire together wire
together right right so so all that is
is the program it's like um I'm having a
bad day it's just a program and then the
brain looks for evidence you know I'm
not making a big enough impact is a
program and then the brain looks for
evidence Evan I'm not this isn't
happening fast enough is the program and
then it looks for evidence okay so we
want to go into the program and rewire
it do you have any questions I had two
things pop up as you were talking that
maybe we'll address those and and you
can tell me they're relevant or not uh
it I think it leads from all the things
that we've insuring one is I had a close
family member who was in politics for a
while and um he ran a Super Clean
Campaign when everybody else was going
like super dirty uh as is as is politics
and he ran for the leadership of the
party and ultimately got smoked like did
not did not do well and that I was I
don't know 11 or 12 and that uh kind
devastated me I remember like I thought
he was going to win like of course you
know he's going to win but then when he
lost we're in this giant stadium and
then I just started crying and I can't
believe we lost like how did we lose and
um there's probably something there in
imprinting of like hey you you you try
to do good and be positive you lose you
right and so there there's uh I don't
know failure again or uh taking the high
road
um so that was the first thought uh and
the second one was around truth and I
haven't I haven't fully formed my
thoughts around this it'll come out a
little messy but you know when I'm
dealing with with people who are in a
really negative spot I don't believe in
negative people just people having
they're in pain and they're having
negative moments and say well you got to
you got to be realistic I I'm just
focused on the truth right it's like
well it's it's the truth that you're
you're choosing to see right you know
the truth is you broke your coffee and
the truth is Onion Man sat next to you
cool but there's there's other truths
too like you get to wake up another day
you still got both your legs you like
there's air to breathe you know like
there's so many amazing truths you could
focus on as well so it's not to say that
the truth you're looking at isn't true
of course it's true but you're just it's
the truth that you choose to focus on
there's amazing things you could focus
on to that are also true and I came to
that because a lot of the some there's
one particular Creator who I loved who
was very positive with his content and
he went really dark of like how the
world is ending and all this kind of
stuff it's like man I can't you know it
it bothered me that he went uh negative
and it and it you know got more views um
and he would say well this is the truth
of what's Happening he like yeah that's
the truth that you're choosing to see
there's still so many amazing truths
that you get to be alive in this moment
right now um so it's just I don't know
those are are the two thoughts that uh
we could take in whatever Direction you
want well well I love and we want to
look at that like underneath of like
being positive like your family member
who ran
for uh that position and then got smoked
is like if I'm positive and and this is
all who you are in the world right then
I'm going to lose and so now the brain
starts picking up all the people who
went dark right and seeing how they're
winning right so you you it's great it's
a great
awareness it's a great awareness and
also you want to be careful with truth
right because to me it's like there's
facts and then there's
stories right it's like this is what
happened I broke my cup now that's the
only thing that happened but the story
is what I create my interpretation of it
and now most people in the world are not
dealing with each other based on facts
they're based on this Story the
interpretation I used to work with
firsttime fathers in the South Bronx in
my old I fatherhood programs and as was
a guy Jamal came and and he was
mad I never should have I never should
have uh uh been loyal she's cheating on
me I'm blah blah blah and and he's going
off and he's about to make a really bad
decision and I say Jamal what and I go
what happened and he goes she was
supposed she said she'd call me at 6
:00 and then I said what else happened
she didn't call me at 6:00 right so I
put that over here and I say okay what
did you make that mean she's cheating on
me I never should have been loyal and
now he's about to make a really bad
decision not based on what actually
happened but on his
interpretation right so even your your
person who you know when we're dealing
with people I always listen for what
actually is happening what's what's
actually what actually happened not the
interpretation of it and a lot of people
live off of just their story around
things right like I'm going to have a
bad day is not what happened what what
happened was I broke the cup I'm going
to have a bad day is a story and I
always tell people if you're going to
create a story feel free but at least
create a story that you can win don't
create don't create a a game in which
you don't
win and this whole like this isn't you
know I have to go negative for me to
make it to 35 million or this isn't
happening fast enough or um you know
being positive doesn't pay off you're
going to get smoked is not a game you're
going to win so we're going to go
through a process now I'm sharing this
with you and your community this is
like first time ever and and I know I'm
I'm so this is what I'm willing to risk
because I I people pay a lot of money
and and we go through a technology we're
going to share with you
so these judgments of yourself are not
true they're just judgments of yourself
not true so read the first three that
you you wrote I'm not growing fast
enough I'm not making enough of an
impact the plan isn't working okay you
want it
slower I see you're you're trying to
write it down I'm not growing fast
enough I'm not making an impact the plan
isn't working and the plan isn't working
yeah there you go good
talking New Yorker you can write fast
too yeah right and listen so so you want
to look at this it's not true now you've
created some timeline in your head
obviously but it's not true it's not
working fast enough it's the plan isn't
working it's just you have a judgment
that it's
not happening fast enough and the plan
isn't working can you see that 100% yeah
yeah so we call these unpaid invoices
cuz we're going to I'm going to give you
a process that you're going to go back
and do homework where you're going to go
and say do I want to keep this or do I
want to pay this invoice off right
because there's it's impacting and and
we don't realize it's impacting but it's
almost like it it's almost like building
a house and the basement is filled with
these lowgrade thoughts so there's a a
shaky foundation and then people think
if I just put positive stuff on top of
it then you know positive talk and this
is you know and they don't clean out the
basement the higher they go the more
likely it's going to
crumble so the higher you go like this
is why bigness has a ceiling right now
because the basement is shaky and if you
just put happy thoughts on top of it
like you histo people historically do it
would be putting like icing on a pile of
uh
dooo sorry for the visual for all your
people but I'm G I I I call it like I
see it it' be like putting that's what
Happy Talk would be affirmations is
great but not if you have a foundation
called I'm not good enough so if I have
a foundation called you know it's uh the
plan isn't working I can put all the
happy thoughts on top of it but the
foundation is the plan isn't working
then it would just be putting icing on a
pile of you know what so let me ask you
this so so the as I as I read those
three out loud and I just wrote this
down like again I just muscle twitch
into positive but but open to like no
maybe that's just icing because I feel
what I wrote down Afters dude I could
double my Channel with one video so what
would that video be yeah so that's where
we're going so so you you've already
done some work in this area you're in
great room so so like what you've taken
up I I mean that's why I say you're the
ideal client because you're so committed
that you're seeing that that twitch is
going to serve us okay so all we want to
do is we want to slow down the twitch
and I'm going to give you a process to
slow down and this is where you're going
to just listen to your intuition
spirit's going to come through you and
there's stuff that'll come out from you
that is like you're going to be like wow
that came from you ever read a book and
you read a book and something and I know
you I love that you post those books
like made it to Page 73 of this book
right you ever read a book and there's
something that you can that you have
just it hit your spirit so much that
you've taken it on in your life like you
could go back years and say I remember
this quote from this book you know like
so so when we do this it could be quote
comes out could be anything um but it's
going to be something that's embedded in
your spirit cuz it's already in you so
here's the process it's called the
presidential Parton
process in America they have a thing
called the presidential pardon do you
know what you have to do to get a
presidential
pardon be friends with the president
nothing that's that's the point it's
good so so this is great for people who
have a lot of judgment for themselves
who think oh my God I'm not good I
there's no way I can for give myself I
got to do something I got to punish
myself no you don't need anything for a
presidential pardon you just need you
know the present and you know the
present which is Evan so here's the
process the president of my life I get
it okay perfect yeah here's the
distinction here and the the pathway to
to a new pathway is self
forgiveness so I'm I'm going to set you
up so what happens is self forgiveness
is a distinction that is way underused
people don't forgive themselves they're
very hard on themselves internally and
then then we have this world in which
people are hard on each other so they
give this kind of there a subconscious
programming called like I'm hard on
myself so I can be hard on my kids and
hard on my friends and hard on my you
know it's just who I am but but like
there's this process where people
internally start beating themselves up
or they start believing this programming
like this plan isn't working you know
the good guy always finishes last right
so we want to look and and understand
that this isn't true as you know it's
just there's a judgment that it's true
like there's just a judgment that the
plan isn't working so here's the process
that I want you to what we're going to
do is how old are you
Evan or about let's give me approximate
if no no no I I just don't remember I'm
43 okay good I have to look at the year
you're amazing so we got so what we want
to do is in in um what I loved about the
old I used to watch like uh John Gotti
and and all those guys who were like
they had a thing called lostra NOA which
was the five families right La laosa
norra laosa NOA thank you thank you
thank you I stand corrected now laosa
NOA was like the five families and if
you anything you wanted to make a a
decision on right you had to you had to
run it through the five families right
so what we're going to do is we're going
to create a process for you it's like
your board of directors your five
families laosan NOA and what it's going
to be is you're going to when you do go
to your homework you're going to bring
in 43y Old
Evan
okay 30 uh 33 year old
Devan 23y old Devan
13-year-old
Evan and then we could throw
seven-year-old Evan in
there okay okay now yeah and what we're
going to do is we're going to take each
of these it's going to take you a while
and you're going to be uninterrupted and
this is the this is what I want you to
complete here it is what you're going to
say initially to yourself is you're
going to sit it's almost a meditation
and it's like and here's the sentence I
forgive
myself for judging
myself
as the plan is not working or um the
good guy always loses right you're going
to put your judgment your low grade
judgment in that I forgive myself for
judging myself as I'm not going fast
enough or
right for the new truth
is and you want to sit and this is where
you know you read the book and and or or
there's something in your life someone
saids something or you you've
experienced something you're going to
just listen you'll be surprised so I
forgive myself for judging myself as
it's not going fast enough for the new
truth is and then listen to Spirit and
then see what comes up and it could be
the opposite of it but it's not always
the opposite it's like it's it's like
something that your spirit tells you so
let's take the fir let's take one of
them which one stands out of your low
grade judgments that you want to work on
from the first three no just from the
whole thing just pick any oh that's a
good
question let's go with um I can't pull
this off good so what you want to do is
we're going to say I forgive myself for
so now I want you to picture in the room
we got 43 y old Evan 33y old Evan 23y
old Evan 13y old Evan 7ye old Evan you
got to just picture them in the room
around you and now you're going to talk
to yourself at 43y Old Evan and you're
going to say I forgive myself for
judging myself
as I I can't pull this off for the new
truth is and then listen to what comes
out of you just and whatever comes out
of you just say it okay so just so I got
this again so so I'm me at 40 three and
I've got you know the other the five
other r one two three four four other R
in the table and then who who's saying
it I'm as you're saying it to your 43y
old self right now just I forgive myself
for judging myself for thinking that I
can't pull this off got it and then for
the new truth is and then list oh and
then and then the them then you got to
slow down and just you could close your
eyes and just listen to see what comes
out of you like you want to go here it's
not going to be here so it's like you
got to attach to kind of like head heart
and guts got to be aligned and you got
you know I forgive myself or judging
myself as you know say someone said
people are stupid for the new truth
is nobody's worthy of my judgment
everybody's worthy of my love right so
so that's and so who's giving me so but
where's the advice is that like the new
truth is is coming from the four Heavens
coming the new truth's coming from you
and then we're going to go to to the
four the four other Evans we're not
going there yet we're going oh they're
not even in the room yet this is just me
talking to me they're just hanging out
in the room you're not talking to them
yet yeah
okay
okay so I forgive myself for judging
myself for thinking that I can't pull
this
off for the new truth
is you're EV carmichel you could do
anything you believe that you can yeah
so good good so what you would do is I
and I would put it in the most powerful
words vibrationally that I found in
human language is I am so we want to do
is we want to shift it to I am Evan what
you say I am Evan I didn't know your
middle name castrilli castrilli
carmichel and I can what do anything I
put my mind to what was it anything that
I believe that I can yeah anything I
believe that I can and you want to write
that down as a statement okay and now
then what you do is you go to Every now
you go 40 33 year old of 23 and you say
the same statement to all your
developmental um Milestones so what
you're doing is if there's anything
that's like lasting over the years we're
just going to clean it up and we're just
letting even if it wasn't there when you
were seven you're just letting them know
laosa Noha that hey this is who I'm
declaring myself to
be and and in that exercise and I am
becoming 3311 or I am talking to 33 just
talking so it's the same thing it would
be like I forgive myself for judging
myself
as what was
the oh that I can't pull this off that I
can't pull this off you're saying the
same exact thing to each developmental
stage you're not changing it for the new
truth is I am Evan casselli Carmichael
and I can do anything I believe I can do
and you just letting all of the five
families know let them know make sense
okay yeah
right we're not asking for permission
here we're just telling them you're
declaring it I am okay so just do it
with the rest of the familyes the same
one oh okay uh perfect so 33-year-old
Evan I forgive myself for judging myself
that the plan isn't working sorry that I
can't pull this off for the new truth is
I'm EV CR carmichel and I can do
anything that I believe that I can good
230 I forgive myself for judging myself
that I can't pull this off for the new
truth is I'm EV K Carle I can do
anything I believe that I
can 13 y 13 let me picture myself at 13
what was I doing at 13 13 okay okay okay
I got
13 uh I forgive myself for
judging myself that I can't pull this
off for the new truth is I'm EV caral
and I can do anything that I believe
that I
can and seven I forgive myself for
judging myself that I can't pull this
off for the new truth is I'm evly
carmical and I can do anything that I
believe that I can bingo so now that's
beautiful I acknowledge you great work
what you're going to do is you're going
to take all of those low grade thoughts
and you're going to take it through the
same process and you're going to create
a new document called this is like your
declaration your I call it my created
life right and that is kind of where
we're going to go from it's like you
know in America they had a declaration
what was it called the Declaration of
Independence yeah when they made the
Declaration of Independence there was no
Independence at the
time right it was a declaration that
they lived
into right so there's a declaration was
like I was a bestselling author before I
wrote my
book declared it I lived into but we
have to clean up the basement first so
we can we can train on neurop Pathways
to see the evidence of this so what
we're doing is that is the process
you're going through and then what we'll
do is I'm going to give you practices in
order to keep training the brain now
what you might not know about me or or I
don't know if I shared this with you
when people ask me who I am I go in the
airport I always answer the same way
because I'm always like connecting with
people and they're like who are you and
I say do you want to know my name or do
you want to know who I am mhm two
different things so if they say like I
want to know who you are I say well you
have about 3 minutes 32 seconds cuz
that's how long it takes cuz I've
created I've taken this work that I do
with myself with others and and cleaned
out the basement of the low grade
thoughts and
rewired myself so much that this is a
way of being you know when we talked
about this is where it all comes
together of who do you need to be being
is a manifestation of your thoughts and
your emotions that gives a vibrational
frequency around you right so you ever
been around someone you've been around
me or you and and you get around them
and you're like man something about
their Vibe they're positive right it's
not cuz they're better or worse than
anyone because they're spending most of
their time on higher frequency thoughts
less Judgment of self and others and
then you get around someone else you
have been around them and you're like oh
I got to get away from her it's not cuz
she's bad it's like she's spending more
of her time on low-grade thoughts more
Judgment of s and others and then
there's stuff in between e it's the
stuff that people don't see that we're
working on here where 's a great guy but
there's these low grade thoughts that
are lingering that are leaking out that
he doesn't even know and those could be
the things keeping him from making the
biggest impact getting the 35 million so
that's why we want to do this work clean
it out and what's amazing is if I shared
if you had 33 minutes and 32 seconds and
you want me to share who I am I'll share
what you'll notice is that people say
this about me without me even saying it
so this is where we're heading to and I
can share a video of it uh or I can
share it now if you ask me who I am go
for it who are you well that's a great
question do you have about three minutes
and 32 seconds let's go should we time
it it used to be four minutes and 32 and
I I do it uh a little quicker you ready
I want to put a Christine I want to put
a little timer here as he saying I think
it would be 4 minutes and 32 if we're
putting timer right put put the timer on
all right here we go
this is who I am I am
love I'm the Divine Light That
illuminates every room I enter I'm a
miracle and I create Miracles with ease
and Grace I'm the most attractive
handsome passionate lover to my
beautiful intelligent and inspiring wife
Jess I am that the God in Me H is the
god in you people inspire me through my
listening I listen generously without
conditions I honor that the person I'm
with right now is the most important
conversation I could ever be in I am
presence and slow down to the speed of
Love That presence liberates others I
have all the time in the world as I'm
always in the infinite time of now I'm
loving kindness I'm vibrant I'm a
student and a teacher my greatest
teachers are my three extraordinary
children Kayla Justice and Omari I'm the
greatest father for my children and I
embody love presence patience kindness
and joy I'm abundance I am wealth I am
Joy I am Prosperity I'm deserving of all
the abundance wealth joy and prosperity
that freely flows to me and through me
I'm the master of the art of living and
I make no distinction between my work
and my play I create anything I desire
with ease and Grace I'm deeply in love
with the love of my life Jess and our
love grows deeper every day I'm
committed to ilu every day for the rest
of our lives I am the creation of love
and devotion I'm certain that my
certainty and commitment are the most
powerful ful forces of creation when
coming from love I trust everyone to do
what they do nobody's worthy of my
judgment everybody's worthy of my love I
am that my way is not the only way and I
stay open to different perspectives what
people think of me is none of my
business I'm a temple of perfect health
I'm always worthy of
forgiveness I love what is including
dying and death which I fully Embrace is
divine I honor that life unfolds
perfectly in every moment I am that my
word and my listening create my world
I'm extremely confident in all my
abilities I respect everyone and
everything especially myself I'm
compassionate and accepting I am fun and
inspiring I love freely and
unconditionally I give graciously and
receive gratefully I am loving service
and my parents Nam me Devin Ludwick
bison and my queen calls me King thank
you there it
is I like it so so is that your
Declaration
of not Independence or is it
Independence so so that's a practice
right that I have trained my brain my my
emotional state every day that's the
first thing I listen to in the morning
the first thing I verbalize every day
and so what's interesting is as I move
through the world people say some
version of that to me without me even
saying it so listen to it meaning what
you've recorded it and you play it back
in your ear yep that's going to be part
of your homework because think about it
people turn on the news and they they
hear you know all these negative thing
and that's how they they fill their
GPS so what I want to do is the first
thing in the morning is fill my GPS in
into a creative way of being so my
neurop Pathways start looking for the
evidence of it every day and that's how
this work all comes together so let me
ask you about that um I haven't done
this exact one we've done this kind of
various forms of it
um I historically have found that um I
get bored of the same thing and then it
just becomes words and not feeling it
and so my adjustment hasn't been to to
uh do it in a different way my
adjustment has been to inject newness in
so uh my morning routine looks like this
first thing is first thing I put on is I
while I'm going to the bathroom you know
go to the bathroom load my phone and I
start playing music yeah good I have I
have a playlist called the believe
playlist that's public it's on my
channel I can go look and they're all
songs that I I mess with and it like
gets me going you you know it's all over
the place uh and like in now I'm
starting
to starting to BCE starting to drive
starting to you know then I put the
airpods on go downstairs and I'm like
fullon dancing in the kitchen I love it
getting my my water and whatever else
just just to just to shake me out of my
Slumber right um and then I go for a
walk get outside within 15 minutes of of
being awake and I'll put on a top 10
video from my own channel because I want
Walt Disney in my ear or Elon Musk in my
ear or Steve Jobs or whatever uh and
it's on my channel so it's always
positive optimistic hopeful like I'll
learn something from somebody um that's
been my
solution but uh you know obviously
totally open to new I guess how do you
not get bored of the same thing or how
do you is it the fact that it's just
you're repeating it and so like it just
hits you deeper every time or I just get
I find the words just turn into
nothingness after a couple times I'm
gonna give you a specific practices so
that doesn't happen so what we're going
to do is we're really going to look at
really where we can make connections
with these Pathways so it's going to be
not only in your speaking but in in what
you're seeing and how you're
experiencing and how you're integrating
it in your world cuz it's like you it's
like how you learn the best right how
you've learned is you go and you learn
something it's knowledge but then you
apply it so we need to make sure that it
becomes part of you so when I whenever
I'm I mean there's some version of that
that people will say about me mostly
almost every day without me even saying
those words because I've it's not only
the brain but it's it's my emotional
state and the vibration I I go into
every Arena so here's the great news I
love you more routine I wouldn't change
one of my old coaches used to say you
need LSD I said what you you telling us
to take drugs he said no laugh sing
dance it's it's the best way to get in a
really high vibration LSD laugh sing and
dance but but like what we're going to
practice here EV you're going to
see it's interesting there's going to be
a shift in in you're just you're going
to feel it in your way of being and and
when we say the guy who started this
conversation a month ago to the guy
who's going to get this 35 million is
not see my first question back then was
who do you need to be to be the guy who
gets the 35 million and what we're
seeing is the guy who got us the 3
million it was amazing and he did that
with a
racket he did that with a racket called
you know I'm I'm I'm a failure he did
that with at the cost of his bigness he
did that with like this plan isn't
working so the person you need to be to
get to 35 million is not the person who
got us to 3
million so what we're doing is we're
cleaning up all the stuff that God is
here we're acknowledging what God is
here we're cleaning up those low grade
thoughts and created creating a way of
being that's going to be have you
powerful beyond
measure let's go and because of your
commitment I have no doubt we're going
to see put the number you got down now I
don't know how many subscribers you have
right now and and we're going to we're
going to see see this thing take off
because the outside world is just a
reflection of our inside world when we
get clean on the inside world that that
goal line stuff I tell people like I've
taking people to billion dollars take
people to Allstar games like like that's
the easy stuff for me because if if we
create the inner game and we we create a
way of being that outer which to do will
be easy the doing will become easy
because you'll be so present in the
being that the doing will happen like
this I'm ready what am I doing what's my
homework coach all right so so the
homework assignment for you is now
you're going to take the five families
and you're going to take each of those
statements and you're going to run it
through the five families and come up
with your new de like your new created
life being mostly in the I am but if you
listen to my de my uh created life it
wasn't all IMS so it doesn't have to be
I AMS and you know these are these are
definitive these aren't affirmations and
mantras those don't work this is why the
the book The Secret didn't work because
it was just like people said if I just
say this then I'll feel this it wasn't
anything wrong it was just one third
correct what we need to do is why the
brain match it with an emotional state
and then you have a a way of being a
transmission that goes out in the world
so your homework is to go through all of
them
and create this new document so in the
answers to the board of
directors combined with the low grade
thoughts that creates the Declaration of
Independence yep so you're what what's
going to happen is it's like remember
your new truth is the first one that you
come up with and then you just bring the
same one to each of them and that's
number one then you take the second one
it doesn't change for each of them you
take them that's number two and then
what we'll do do is that is going to be
um going to create a document for you
and then from that I'll give you some
practices to work on from that that will
keep it going okay so what do you want
to see in my document you want to just
see the new truth is for all new truths
the IM AMS I am Evan casselli casselli
castrilli castrilli Carmichael that's
why you corrected me on laosa NOA
because you're a true Italian my fault
my
fault and and so you want those to be
the new truth and then quick we'll we'll
get together and I just give you some
some practices that we're going to take
off and then we can track your 35
million from that okay so how about I
We'll add it on to this video I'll go
through this exercise I'll I'll uh I'll
shoot you what I came up with and then
you record a little whatever my bonus
thing is I need to work on and we'll
we'll include it in this video when it
comes out that's it so let me ask you
this what would uh what has been the
most valuable thing that you you've
heard thought or experienced in our time
together
today um just your your
um your
love I love you brother you're power
you're a Force for good in the world
thank you for
noticing come on you're taking my line
away from
me Dr Evan Dr
Devin all right appreciate you man thank
you appreciate you too brother take care
okay so that was a fun session and now
you can see why I love Devon so much he
gave me some great homework and I wrote
down three things that I have to do
going to take you inside that Journey so
number one was I wanted to find what
that exact Tupac quote was so I can
reference it and think about it and use
it as inspiration number two was if I
wasn't afraid of disappointing people
what would I do that was a question that
came up that I didn't have an immediate
answer to in our session but I think
it's going to be commenting on something
that's in news right now I've always
kind of stayed away from talking about
the news too much because I feel like I
don't have enough context I don't know
enough about both sides uh and I'm
worried about saying the wrong thing and
and upsetting people and as a result I
don't spread more belief and so I'm
going to craft a tweet be my little
homework today is craft a tweet and
share it and we'll see what happens and
number three was come up with my I
statements that come from talking with
my board of directors and get that to
Devon so can give me some extra feedback
and assignments let's go all I've been
busy at work let me show you what I have
been doing so step one is find the Tupac
quote that was an easy one let's get
some momentum so the quote was wasn't
about being a president it was I'm not
saying I'm going to change the world but
I guarantee that I will spark the brain
that will change the world and again why
I love that is uh I don't necessarily
have to have all the answers to a lot of
the things that are going on in the
world but the goal is to spark the brain
to spark the person to believe in
something greater to Believe In Hope and
positivity and optimism and I could just
be a voice for believe that that is
enough and so I want to spark the brain
that might have that big change in
Impact number two was I went to chat GPT
and I asked them to look at the whole
Lex fredman thing that was one of the
topics of discussion with Devin and I
said uh with the whole martial arts
saying hey what are some of the
characteristics that make up Lex Ran's
responses and this is what it came up
with and I liked it and chbt is a great
tool to use for brainstorming and just
as a co-pilot and this was their
response a holistic thinking empathetic
understanding long-term perspective
constructive criticism wisdom oriented
thinking and optimistic Outlook and I
like all of these things I mean I would
add believe to that list for myself but
a lot of these things I like and and
believe in and it just gives an extra
little point of perspective so when I'm
looking at some situation that's
happening in the world I could just run
it through this filter and then the next
bit of homework was to use that to then
craft a reply to Something in the news
that I might be afraid of disappointing
people on and so the one that I chose
was about the Israel Palestine issue
that's happening right now and I mean
it's been happening for uh a long time
but especially now with the war going on
I'm filming this on November 3rd
2023 and so my response is going to be
deeply saddened by the ongoing crisis in
Israel and Palestine it's Times Like
These we need more empathy understanding
and strong leadership to PVE a path
towards peace and growth let's Believe
In A Better Tomorrow where Unity tries
over War now that may not seem like a a
big deal or um anything that powerful uh
or a big step at all but for me it's
actually a big deal because I don't
usually comment on these things uh
because again I feel like I need to have
the answers so I'm going to I'm going to
post this and we'll see what the
response is if there is any and if
there's any negativity or or positivity
we'll see what it is and it's a good
step it's a good step towards even more
momentum so step one and two of my
homework is done now I got to work on
step three which is the deeper board of
directors work and coming up with my I
statements to give to Devon okay so it's
been a day since I posted I posted to
Instagram as well as Twitter and let's
go look at the results so let's dive in
here was my post and listen uh I was
surprised Ur by all the love look at
look at the first comment Mr Devin
bandison the first comment says love you
brother uh R retirement Transformer
thank you for posting this message I
believe in humanity Oneness so a lot of
Love Actually at the beginning uh from a
lot of people most of these the people
who follow me so this was great I mean
it's always great to feel like the
messenger critton is having an impact
love always wins Etc this is this was
awesome uh then I got a bunch of things
that I kind of expected right people
just sharing their own perspective
standing with Israel free Palestine free
the hostages uh free Palestine people on
both sides you know uh a lot of the free
Palestine here uh other people coming on
the other side and this is you know
basically what I expected um the the
harsher ones are when it gets to be
criticism so you know these people are
not uh they're not being critical but
some of them you know open your eyes
before your heart it's on both sides
actually that's not too bad better
tomorrow free
Palestine you know then somebody for the
Israel side bro I like your content but
if it's to write such BS just keep
silent it shows the exact opposite of
empathy making me want to unfollow to be
honest this is where you know it hurts a
little more and there there wasn't
anybody who I'm super close with um but
it makes you look at is it worth it is
it worth it poster or not
um so I'm still I'm still uh reflecting
on it you know some of the other
criticism hey Evan thank you for the
message unfortunately it's not really a
war when one side I that one's not too
bad with all due respect this statement
is as reflective as silence this is not
a time to pick neutrality and statements
like this you know so you know a lot
more negative on that side
here uh if people just saying their own
comments it's fine but it's when it it
gets more attacking right the what we
talked about with Deon about not liking
to leave a bad taste in people's mouth
uh playing safe not even mentioning all
the genocide is happening defending by
bombing refugee camps in
hospitals a real leader is able to stand
up and say the truth even when it's
difficult the truth is is a genocide are
you able to stand up and call it out as
such so if you for Palestines put they
in okay unfollow after all Israel did
are you still speaking about peace are
you out of your mind right and so do I
respond to these do I just let it go do
I you know still still processing still
processing so as you can see it's a mix
and super grateful for all the people
who uh are in my community who who
supported um I expect a whole bunch of
people
to come up with just their perspective
and their opinions and then the other on
who are going to be just nasty and
critical and it's less a reflection of
me and more where they're at and the
pain that they've been through and
they're whatever you're taking aside um
well whenever you go into something
where there are two sides uh everybody
has their own bias you know whether it's
Sports whether it's politics whether
it's religion whether it's whatever the
thing is and the the hotter the flame
the more people are going to be agitated
and
it's just a matter of making sure that
I'm proud of the statements that are
going out and I do believe in in a
better tomorrow and I do believe that we
need more belief and I do believe that
I'm not going to make everybody happy
and I don't have the answers and again
back to the Tupac quote I don't have to
have the answers but I hope to spark the
brain that might be able to and what I
also remind myself in moments like this
is all the people who didn't comment you
know there's all the people who didn't
comment on this who are just giving a uh
a heart you know they give a thumbs up
they give a like to it but they don't
comment or people who are just impacted
it's easy to look at the vocal minority
of people who
are uh either either saying great things
but also coming out and being you know
uh attacking it's easy to look at the
vocal minority and make a decision based
off of that but it's all the other
people who aren't saying anything who
are just like liking it who are
hopefully being impacted by it who this
is part of being the light in the dark
and whatever that version of looks like
for you um so this is a good experiment
I I like the push outside the comfort
zone I think honestly the hardest part
of all of it was just what is the
statement that I feel connected to you
know there's a great message about we
tend to play small because we see a
faster path to a lesser goal you know
the the bigger goal the big impact you
don't know how to do it I don't know how
to do it and it takes more work to do
and so we settle for a smaller goal
because the path is defined where the
biggest challenge was what is the
statement that I would be proud of
releasing not so much the negative
feedback but what is a statement that
I'd be proud of releasing and that takes
more work and more effort and more
thought and it may not even have been
the most profound statement that that I
put up but it was one that um reflected
what I was thinking and so it's extra
work uh which is required to go hit your
bigger goal so I like to push outside
the comfort zone and we'll keep doing it
so that's some of my homework done now I
got to do the main one which was the
activity that Devon gave me
of looking through all of the uh getting
my board of directors together looking
through the limiting statements and it's
now a couple days later it's Sunday and
I've dedicated some time to be able to
sit down in my office and uh have some
alone time and I'm going to go through
it we'll see what I come up
with okay so for every low grade thought
I wrote wrote down what the new truth
was after forgiving myself for every age
that Devon said so here's what I came up
with the first is the low great thought
and the second is the new truth and
there's some overlap between the
responses so I'm not growing fast enough
becomes every day is a new chance to
make history I'm not making enough of an
impact same thing every day is a new
chance to make history the plan isn't
working the new thought or the new truth
is great things come to me I don't know
what to do the new truth is just focus
on who I need to be this is the one that
comes up the most people won't help me
became people want to be a part of
something that matters they will help if
I ask I won't figure this out becomes
just focus on who you need to be I can't
get people to care becomes all that
matters is that I care people come for
the CBS not my contribution becomes it's
never been about me and my story and
perspective help people I haven't
mobilized my subscribers becomes I just
need to give them something to mobilize
around my content is not important
enough becomes every day is a new chance
to make history I can't pull pull this
off becomes just focus on who I need to
be I'm not bold enough to do this
becomes boldness is a choice it's at my
fingertips and I have access to it
whenever I want I'm not taking the
actions fast and that becomes just focus
on who I need to be the dark is more
powerful and the light becomes humans
are good they they are just in a lot of
pain I'm not bringing enough value
becomes every day is a new chance to
change someone's life and I'm stuck
becomes just focus on who I need to be
okay so my next round of homework is
done it was a fun exercise I go through
sometimes looking back on the younger
you and thinking of you know who you
were back then and the mistakes or
choices you were making was helpful and
I love coming up with the new truth
because it's a reminder of who I want to
be in the game that I want to play the
impact that I want to make and some of
the key sentences there are things that
uh that I will need every day every day
because every day I can go off and make
history or every day I can go
and uh do the status quo and so it's a
great reminder and great seeds for my
own Declaration of Independence so I'm
going to send this off to Devon and see
what he gives me back so I gave my
homework to Devon and he wants to hop
back on another video call for round
three to go even deeper into this so
we're going to end the episode here and
if you want to see the first episode in
this series where he pushed me for the
first time that was supposed to be
private but we made it public anyway the
video right there next to me continue to
believe and I'll see you there